And the answer is, because n is a str but we're
treating it like an int. Let's look at our code again. So
on our code here, we're getting from the request and we're
just storing on th, in the variable n here. Now the problem
is, when things come out of the requests there're always strings.
So if we want a, if we want to be an integer,
we need to make it an integer. Let's go ahead and do
that. So basically, if n was specified, convert it into an integer.
Now let's see if it works in our browser.
Okay, here we are, N equals 1. I'm going
to hit Enter, and N indeed equals 1. And if we set it to something else, N does
not equal 1. And if I set it to
a string, we don't get anything. And actually what
really happened, is we got an error because we
tried to convert the string Steve into an integer and
Python did not like that. We're not going to go ahead and fix that,
but what I wanted to show you, was that when you expect an
integer as a parameter from user, you need to actually convert it. because
the web application, or the browsers, or the HTTP has no idea what's an
integer and what's a string, so you have to actually do that check
yourself. And if we want to make that previous example work, we would have to
check to see is the string all digits first, and then, only then
convert it to an integer. So, it's a common mistake, I actually, I made
it when I was doing this lesson in the first place,
and so I thought I would let you see it as well.